نبدأ بالأخبار العاجلة من
إسرائيل حيث تم إطلاق وابل من الصواريخ في وقت
مبكر من يوم السبت على البلاد.
يقول المسؤولون الإسرائيليون إن هناك
إصابات متعددة، بعضها خطير،
ووفاة شخص واحد على الأقل. بدأ الوابل حوالي الساعة
6:30 صباحًا بالتوقيت المحلي عندما كان معظم
الناس  من المحتمل أننا كنا نائمين، الدخان الذي
تراه في السماء، هناك آثار من صفارات
الإنذار الصاروخية التي تم إطلاقها في أقصى
الشمال حتى تل أبيب،
انضم إلي حداش جولد لقناة سي إن إن الآن على الهواء مباشرة اه من القدس أم
أنا لا أعتقد أنني رأيت شيئًا
كهذا منذ فترة  في حين يبدو أن هذا
هجوم منسق واسع النطاق وحتى
تقارير عن وجود مقاتلين فلسطينيين داخل
إسرائيل، وهو أمر غير عادي، فما الذي
تسمعونه، نعم، هذه الكثافة هي في الحقيقة
شيء غير مسبوق منذ الساعة 6:30
هذا الصباح، حيث كان في الأساس
وابلًا متواصلًا من الهجمات
تنطلق صفارات الإنذار الحمراء للصواريخ في جميع أنحاء البلاد،
هاتفي الذي يحتوي على هذا التطبيق الذي يخبرك
عندما تنطلق صفارات الإنذار في جميع أنحاء
البلاد لم يتوقف عن الاهتزاز منذ الساعة
6:30 صباحًا مما يمنحك
فكرة عن مدى شدة هذا الهجوم
يحدث في الساعة 6:30 صباحًا يوم
السبت، كما تعلم أن معظم الناس يكونون
نائمين، كما أنه يوم السبت، لذا إذا كنت
متدينًا ولم يكن لديك أي من
الأجهزة الإلكترونية الخاصة بك، فستسمع أصوات
صفارات الإنذار تنطلق في حيك
ولكنك لن تفعل ذلك.  ليس لديك هواتف محمولة
أو أجهزة تلفزيون أو أي شيء آخر من هذا القبيل، لقد
سمعنا بالفعل عن
إصابات ووفيات، فقد
قُتلت امرأة واحدة على الأقل في السبعينيات من عمرها،
وسمعنا عن عدة إصابات أخرى أه أه
بما في ذلك الإصابات الخطيرة مايكل،
تنفجر هذه الصواريخ  في جميع أنحاء البلاد،
كل شيء من الجزء الجنوبي من
إسرائيل في المنطقة السلبية في بيفا إلى
شمال تل أبيب حتى حول
المطار، مما قد يؤدي إلى
احتمال إغلاق المطار، وفي
الواقع حتى هنا في القدس عندما
كنت في طريقي إلى استوديوهات سي إن إن
سمعت ما لا يقل عن اثنين مما بدا وكأنه
دوي نوع من الانفجارات في السماء
ولم تنطلق صفارات الإنذار داخل القدس
نفسها ولكن هذا يعطيك فكرة إذا
كنا نسمع شيئًا ما في القدس
عادةً ما تكون القدس
بعيدة عن هذه الأنواع  من الصراعات
التي تعطيك فكرة عن مدى حدة
هذا الأمر، ثم لدينا شيء
جديد هو هذه التسللات التي
أكدها الجيش الإسرائيلي أنه كانت هناك
بعض عمليات التسلل التي يسمونها
عدد من الإرهابيين الذين توغلوا
إلى الأراضي الإسرائيلية من قطاع غزة.  لقد
رأيت تقارير عن مسلحين في
مؤخرة شاحنات صغيرة يطلقون النار في
أحياء في جنوب
إسرائيل فقط أستمع لأسمع ما إذا كان
بإمكاني سماع إعلان من المحتمل
من الشارع يعطيك فكرة
عن مدى أه هذا
غير مسبوق تمامًا هنا فكرة
تسلل المسلحين  إسرائيل لا نعرف
هل جاؤوا هذا الصباح
هل كانوا بالفعل داخل
البلاد أه قبل أن يحدث هذا
لأن هناك آلاف العمال
من غزة الذين يسمح لهم بدخول
إسرائيل كل يوم
بتصاريح عمل للدخول إليها لا  واضح ولكن
كيف تمكن هؤلاء الأشخاص من الدخول
بالطبع السؤال هو لماذا
يحدث هذا؟ نتلقى تصريحات بينما
نتحدث من حماس يقولون إنهم
يزعمون أنهم أطلقوا أكثر من 5000
صاروخ باتجاه إسرائيل أم يقولون أنهم
أطلقوا من قبل  حذر العدو من أنهم
يتحدثون عن
مجمع اللايموس والذي يُعرف أيضًا باسم جبل الهيكل، وهو
مكان مقدس جدًا لكل من اليهود
والمسلمين قائلًا إن أه اليهود
يدنسون أن إسرائيل تقوم
بتدنيس MOs لأنه
كان هناك عدة مئات أه من الزوار اليهود
إلى المجمع خلال الأسبوع الماضي أو
نحو ذلك خلال الأعياد اليهودية،
يُسمح لغير المسلمين بزيارة
المجمع، لكن هذا موضوع حساس للغاية
هناك حول من يمكنه الزيارة
ومتى سواء كانوا يصلون هناك أم
لا، يذكر بيان حماس أيضًا
ما يجب عليهم فعله.  يقولون إنهم المئات من الشهداء
الذين قتلوا على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي هذا العام، ونحن بالطبع
ننشر منذ أسابيع وأشهر
عن كثافة الاشتباكات في الضفة الغربية
بين المسلحين والجيش
الإسرائيلي، والتوغلات العسكرية الإسرائيلية المنتظمة
في
المدن الفلسطينية حيث نقوم  لقد كان هناك عدد قياسي من القتلى،
وكان هناك أيضًا عدد قياسي
من الهجمات الفلسطينية ضد الإسرائيليين
داخل الأراضي الإسرائيلية نفسها، لقد
كانت فترة متوترة للغاية ولكني أعتقد أن
هذا كان بمثابة مفاجأة لأنه
على الرغم من وجود بعض الاشتباكات على طول
السياج والاحتجاجات على طول  السياج
بين غزة وإسرائيل، كانت هناك
بعض التوترات في القدس، كان هناك
هذا النوع من الوضع المستمر في
الضفة الغربية، شدة ما
رأيناه للتو في الساعات القليلة الماضية هو
شيء لا أعتقد أن أحداً كان
يتوقعه لأنه كان هناك  لا توجد
نقطة انطلاق واضحة تسببت في ذلك، وهذا هو الأمر
المفاجئ للغاية بشأن كل
هذا، ويجب أن ننظر أيضًا إلى
التداعيات الجيوسياسية لما
يحدث الآن بالطبع، ومن
المحتمل أن يكون هذا مرتبطًا بطريقة ما
أنه على الرغم من أننا
يجب أن نبحث الآن عما
سيكون عليه الرد، فإن رد
الجيش الإسرائيلي سيخبرك، وأنا
متأكد تمامًا أنه سيكون كبيرًا جدًا لأن هذا
كان هجومًا كبيرًا غير مسبوق
بما في ذلك عمليات التسلل على
الأرض التي نعرفها  أنه تم إطلاع رئيس الوزراء
بالفعل على أنه يجري
تقييمًا أمنيًا، وعلينا أن نتوقع
ردًا كبيرًا للغاية من
الجيش الإسرائيلي، وقد يستمر هذا
لبعض الوقت